let's answer some questions always great
to answer audience questions on Friday
you can email them in leave them as a
voicemail 2192 david p tweet audience
questions to us post them on Facebook
post them on reddit whatever you want
we'll take the audience questions first
one is from Nate Nate says hey would you
be willing to become extremely ugly
physically if it allowed you to live for
a thousand years at any physical age
that you chose my instinct is that this
is not a tough question i would say yes
i mean i think that if i could live a
thousand years at my current age roughly
my current age and health and whatever
uh assuming the entire fainting on
planes then gets the all-clear which
we're going in that direction but yes
assuming that uh i think that the answer
would be as i think in a thousand years
i'd be able to figure out how to surpass
any impediment I might have from being
extremely ugly physically and that what
I would learn from living a thousand
years in good health and seeing what's a
thousand years away into the future for
me it's a pretty easy yes I don't know
usually these are really tough where I
say you know on the one hand but on the
other hand but I I think this is a yes
for me Plus how ugly are we talking here
I mean I think that has to be to find a
little bit can I go out during the day
still right yeah I mean are we talking I
don't want to say anything you know we
want to maybe give specific examples but
are we talking about horrible
disfigurement to the point where you may
not even be comfortable leaving your
house or just like a UH still within the
normal scope but just basically as ugly
as a sort of general person might be I
don't even know what words I should be
using here of sort of taking the
question as it's written might my
instinct is that if I can leave the
house during the day without creating
chaos on the streets that my curiosity
about the future is significant enough
that I would accept this trade yeah I
think we're gonna differ here I don't
think I'd want to live for a thousand
years I mean really a hundred to two
hundred should be enough I think I know
what though yeah I mean it's tough
because I guess you're not ailing you're
not aging as you would normally right
you're gonna be stuck at the same age
but I mean I think a hundred two hundred
years that's that's about enough but I
am interested in this
concept of enough enough it enough to do
what is enough judges suggests enough to
accomplish X Y or Z right so a hundred
or two hundred years would be enough for
what for just the full happy life I
think I think that would be the right
amount of time so you're less curious
about what our planet would be like in a
thousand years I'm actually kind of
worried way more thigh change going no
I'm worried you mean could we even
support life that that far down the road
I what we it's it said that were at this
point of hugely accelerating development
and advancement in terms of Technology
and whatever and feeling that were on
the cusp of that I don't know if my
current natural lifespan will really get
me far enough to see some of the
incredible things that will note no
doubt be around in four or five hundred
years and that's really where my genuine
curiosity would make me think that this
is it if it were a deal with the devil
that I'd be striking that it would be an
interesting one to me I I guess for some
people that's not as interesting plus if
you're guaranteed a thousand years that
means you kinda have some immunity like
you can just jump off buildings and be
completely invincible I don't understand
whenever I hear about if your lifespan
would become a thousand years I don't
see that as immortality like you can
still be run over by a bus i don't think
i still see it as if you don't suffer a
catastrophic accident or something like
that your lifespan could allow you to
live a thousand years you're going more
into like you're come you're immortal
you could step in front of a bus and you
would just bounce off and be fine which
I guess I mean burp in a fantasy world
no matter what it's just what your
fantasy world versus my fantasy world
but I assume that you would still be
susceptible to sort of getting hit by a
by a meteor or something like that sure
well you can live your 1,000 years and
let me know how it goes alright so
that's my answer I don't know if people
have am I just not considering something
that would make me change my answer let
me know